okay so Shazam Fury of the Gods is now
out and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the ending of
the movie discussing its post-credits
scene and also going over what this
could mean for the future of the DCU is
it Canon is it not we don't know but
there are some things in it that we know
at the very least will be getting
carried over to Future films and shows
however there are some things that I
think might lead nowhere and with us
knowing the first phase of the DCU I
think we can kind of see where things
are going heavy spoilers from this point
now and if you haven't had a chance to
check out the movie then check out now I
know most of you might not care so if if
you haven't seen it I won't be mad at
you either just don't kick off in the
comments here don't be it and without
the way let's get into the breakdown
[Music]
we
will annihilate everything
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that okay so Shazam Fury of the
Gods culminates with Shazam defeating
the daughters of Atlas along with the
dragon this is inside a dome in which
Shazam needs to supercharge the Wizard's
staff and also tell you what song you're
listening to eh
now inside he does this which kills
Calypso the dragon and all the beasts
that have been summoned to Earth however
this exacts the toll on Billy in doing
this unfortunately kills him this leads
into a big funeral scene with Freddy
asking if there's any way to bring him
back but in order to do this they need
to charge the staff this requires the
power of a God and a Wonder Woman Who
that could be God stick to saving the
world kid Shazam Fury of the guards
rated PG-13 yeah in an amazing marketing
move that Rivals James Gunn telling you
that none of this matters we had Diana's
Rivals spoiled by one of the recent
trailers Wonder Woman comes in a music
bears away and she charges the staff and
brings Billy back now this kind of plays
upon the Headless Superman scene from
the last film and it's nice seeing gal
get out back because if there's one
thing that DC's told me it's that these
people returning definitely means
something Shazam bursts out of the
ground like a zombie but he's okay and
eventually he also gives the rest of the
Shazam Lee their powers back anyway
Shazam then flirts with Diana and says
that he's gonna be 18 soon nice she says
that he should stick to saving the world
though and as we know from Justice
League everyone's a younger man to her
but it seems like it's gonna be okay and
after we jump to a trip back home we
watch The Wizard returning like he's
used one of our manscape codes like the
genie at the end of Aladdin he's decided
to go and explore the world but before
he leaves he finally reveals what
Billy's superhero name is he tells him
it's Shazam which is a bit obvious but
we then cut to Freddy who says that he
thinks they can still beat it now that
ends the movie to Elvis's Little Less
Conversation and from here we go to our
first post credit scene in which
shazam's asked to be in the JSA you know
we see John economos and Amelia Harcourt
who by my count has now appeared in more
movies than most of the other
superheroes just don't tell my wife yet
I'm gonna look bad when I don't even let
her feature in the background of a video
on the clips Channel and guns making his
wife the Nick Fury of the DCU you know
when I was watching it I was thinking
it's kind of like when you may get a new
girlfriend and she starts showing up
everywhere but what's going on with this
scene exactly well it starts off with
them approaching Shazam out in the woods
whilst he's shooting down a bunch of
beer bottles and they offer him a
position on the GSA they phrase it and
say they want to know if he's going to
be interested in joining the Justice
which is when he immediately Cuts them
off and says yes but he he's thinking
league and it's just the Justice Society
which bums him out because he wants to
be on a team with Wonder Woman they make
a joke about changing the name of it to
stop people getting confused because
it's pretty stupid having two teams with
Justice in the name he throws out some
new ones from his phone and throughout
the film there's this running gag about
superhero names in general there's some
little nods here to other Heroes like
the Avengers and the authorities which
we now are coming as part of James
Gunn's chapter one now the first Marvel
not to me is kind of just giving a nod
to The Wider universe and all the things
that have happened over the decades with
the two companies Shazam was of course
originally called Captain Marvel and the
eternals was filled with lines about
Superman and Batman as for the authority
we have some things that could be
connecting to that and in case you don't
know they're basically DC's answer to
the boys published at the end of the 90s
this Warren LS creation was super over
the top in its score and violence and is
basically what you'd call your reverse
Justice League featuring characters I
could follow the song God and Jenny
Sparks this team is probably most known
for having the character midnighter
amongst its ranks I am really excited to
see what they do with it and though I've
been I've been ragging on James Gunn a
lot in this video I do think that his
sensibilities are perfect for that kind
of project now I'm gonna go on a limb
here and give a little dude
so I actually think that this post crate
scene potentially came from a full gun
took over everything the JSA of course
featured in Black Adam and I think that
this scene might have potentially been
setting up how Shazam was gonna meet him
but they're of course enemies in the
comics and Black Adam really came to the
fourth brand as a Shazam villain
according to reports The Rock was
supposed to be cameoing in this movie
originally but he shut that idea down
and refused to do it so yeah I think
this was probably Warner Brothers trying
to set it up so that Shazam eventually
featured in Black Adam too which we know
isn't coming down the line originally
the way it was meant to be the rock
wanted that movie to be Superman vs
Black Adam but since gun took over it
has pretty much been mothballed I also
think that the hardcore and economos
thing was supposed to tie into season 2
of Peacemaker which we now know has been
kind of warped into the Amanda Waller
show sent it around her this will
probably build upon the events of the
show and it will also potentially focus
on Amanda and her relationship with her
daughter now Walla is is a very big
character in the DCU and through how we
can explore the direction that things
are going normally she's used as someone
who introduces the team but going
forward they can instead use as someone
who lays the groundwork of where things
will be heading she obviously has task
force x on her side but it's clear that
she's also trying to create her own
legitimate group in the Justice Society
now Theory timer theater but I actually
think that that she's gonna be the one
who puts together the authority and this
will be her trying to bridge the gap
between the suicide squad and Justice
League they're both opposite ends of the
spectrum The Authority is basically the
middle ground in which you haven't
hinged Heroes who think they're doing
good so jump out jump out of those two
Theory times with me and then we'll go
into our second post-create scene
breakdown now if you cast your mind back
to the first Shazam post credit scene
then you might remember it involved
doctors Savannah in jail which is where
he was scribbling symbols on the wall he
was visited by Mr Mind who said that
there were other ways to gain magic and
he said that there were Seven Realms out
there that were theirs for the taking
well that went out two years later
unlike a DC movie announcement nothing
has happened we catch Savannah still
surrounded in scribblings and he now has
a full-on beard Mr mine apologizes and
says that his plan just needs more time
but it won't be long until everything
comes together Savannah is furious
because he's 57 years old now but mind
apologizes because it takes him a long
time to get places Savannah demands that
he tells in the plan but Mr mine says
that he just has one more thing to do he
then screws off which ends the scene and
the movie as a whole so what could be
happening here well luckily I did a big
breakdown for this on the last movie
that kind of covers the ins and outs of
where this may lead now Mr mind is a
telepathic green worm who amplifies his
voice through a radio speaker around his
neck first introduced in 1943 by Otto
binder the character was made as a
novelty villain to stand out against the
more fearsome foes like Lex Luthor and
the Red Skull he created the monster
Society of evil which included Savannah
Captain Nazi which I can't really say
without getting demonetize and even real
life figures like Hitler and Mussolini a
mastermind of evil he actually wishes to
charge himself up to become a hyperfly
which is his final form in the comics
however in order to do this he needs to
build up his brain waves which he does
by pulling in parts of the space-time
Continuum Mr mind has the ability to eat
time in space and he's been used as a
way to trim continuity in Canon which
could pull into what's going on with the
DCU in the past mind is a time in years
from the timeline and thus if they want
to pull him into that then they could
quite easily use the goofy Little
Critter to explain why some things are
different in Gunn's version it's pretty
much the exact same post credit scene as
the one from the last movie and when it
first started off I genuinely thought
there was an issue with the film but no
here it is now I was thinking about this
before I think they could even have this
as a stupid running joke that goes on
for years and years I think it would be
so stupid if every two years we
get a post credit scene like this where
Mr mine returns to find Savannah
slightly older and looking worse and
worse dude for like do it for 10 years
make it the longest running joke ever
and then just have him get to a point
where he shows up and Savannah is dead
that would be hilarious to me and I
think it's so stupid that I actually
hope they end up doing it dude for the
laughs mate make the joke last
longer than the DCU yeah anyway that
sets up the future of the DCU and how I
think that things will play into it I
don't know how well Shazam is gonna do
at the box office though and at the
moment it looks like it's gonna make
negative money so who knows how things
are going to shake up in the future it's
also rotten on Rotten Tomatoes now and
though I thought it was okay I think
gun's looking for more highly esteemed
projects to to get the ball rolling with
his films now we do know that at least
for now Shazam hasn't featured in the
lineup of Gods and Monsters And Thus
he's either gonna be announced as a new
project or is something down the line
the rock did say that black item
wouldn't feature in the first phase of
the upcoming DCU and the Shazam could
potentially be the same too however no
one is saying nothing and I think that
if this movie underperforms then they
will probably look at reworking things
within the DCU it's difficult to know
whether this is gonna fit in with Gunn's
version of the future and I think that
the reason they're keeping their mouths
closed is because they really want to
see how the movie does I think that's
across the board with everything coming
this year too including whether they're
keeping Ezra is The Flash Jason Momoa or
Aquaman and so on and so forth
personally I think that they should have
waited until these movies had been
released before they announced that they
were rebooting elements of them because
it kind of kills the momentum of this
when we think they're leading to a
cul-de-sac it's something that Warner
Brothers have done before and I always
think that if you don't need to open
your mouth then you don't need to open
your mouth guns movies won't come out
until 2025 at the earliest I think that
they could have just announced he was
taking over and let these movies play
out and then announce what they're doing
just just my personal feelings and I
think that the hardcore will still
likely come back around in the Waller
show with them clearly trying to form
other teams it's also important to bear
in mind that there have been several
different versions of The Flash shown to
test audiences and these will come with
different endings these have featured
different Batman and I was watching a
video on the scenes by the Channel
Austin fans the other day I brought up a
really great Point obviously Gunners cut
things from upcoming movies such as
Henry Cavill appearing in The Flash and
Ben Affleck appearing in Aquaman 2.
Austin said that Gunn would at least
have to give the green light on these
posts credit scenes for them to be
included in Shazam and therefore the
fact that these lead into other films
teas at Zachary Levi is possibly coming
back down the line the frustrating thing
is that we don't know and this you kinda
can't expect people to get that invested
when they don't know what's happening
now as are my feelings on the movie Thor
love and Thunder with a script and yeah
take that how you want anyway that's the
end of the video and I hope you enjoy
the breakdown we are in competition
right now giving away the Superman 4K
box set of three subscribers on the 15th
of April and all you have to do to be
when the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
beat the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now save that to
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want to smell us to watch
then make sure you check out one of our
breakdowns linked on screen right now
we've probably put more effort into that
to be fair but you know it's Shazam and
I don't know how well this is gonna do
but yeah definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking to the video I've been Paul and
I'll see you next time take care peace